[Music]
what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
the pregame yo what's going on people
King rich is back again with another
podcast good evening and hi and welcome
to Auntie Jenny's Village actually
Jenny's podcast it's your boy The Fresh
Prince of someone
coffee free for four months okay I gotta
say that how could everyone have someone
out there for them when there's more
women than men now I'm not saying you
have to be submissive to every old waste
man walking around I'm just saying that
it would be femininity would be in your
nature breaking it is to find somebody
you're compatible with that you'd like
not just if you're saying generation and
that likes the same things that you do
going out having fun get out okay okay
then then get out then get out faster
then get out I'm not here to get
canceled today most men want a woman
that has some degree of femininity where
they feel like they're taking care of
taking care of I'm a lady like I'm
submissive and you'll be surprised
because I will say what I want to say
now and I'll say what I want to say with
my mind but my demeanor doesn't change
and I'm gonna look down on him because
at the end of the day whoever you're
with is a reflection of you what has
happened to society that has made the
normal man a waste man I would feel so
bad asking a guy to buy like a three
thousand dollar bag
now he's
[Music]
what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
the pregame
[Applause]
before I start don't forget to subscribe
to the channel and bring that
notification Bell that we are going to
be notified of my daily videos like the
video on your way in let's get started
um a couple announcements before we
start the show
um the first is that if you guys have
any questions for the panel uh make sure
you Super Chat them blessing um over
what amount are we reading today
yeah yeah you're feeling generous today
okay all right five over five dollars we
are reading um these super chat
questions or comments uh be nice guys
um also um subscribe to our two clips
channels just pearly clips and pearl
daily and also um
to open the chat today how many likes do
we need 1 000 likes all right guys a
thousand likes and we will open up the
chat today um so we have four membership
tiers the first tier lets you be a part
of the chat second tier Discord Vlogs
third tier connect with me on social
media and a fourth Tierra one-on-one
call with me once a month want to know
how to get a million subscribers in a
year make sure you sign up for that one
also guys follow my Instagram just
pearly things one a lot of you guys
submit um topics videos for the show um
sometimes we do reactions live on the
show we have a couple today
um so make sure you guys sign up or
follow my Instagram there
um also we have a Google form me and
blessing uh tell them where we're going
on Tuesday tell them where we're going
Miami we're going to Miami on Tuesday
I'm for some podcasts so we're gonna do
meetups in every city so make sure you
sign up to the Google Forum so we can do
that um I think we're going to Miami La
uh California
Vegas oh yeah Vegas Nashville and we're
going all over it's a long trip
um so but that means we actually are not
going to have shows for a couple weeks
now so if you guys do want to see a live
show King riches is going to be doing a
live show five days a week so go
subscribe to his channel um he is under
the jpt network as well and also
subscribe to Auntie Jenny um she is in
Barbados right now but when she is back
I'm sure she's going to do shows again
or some something well I'll let you guys
know okay
um welcome to the show guys
um to start everyone say your name your
age your relationship status and a fun
fact about yourself
oh hi how are you I'm good thank you how
are you good hello my name is Ashton I'm
24 years old I am single and a fun fact
about me is there's only one me there
really is only one me
I think that's the funnest fun fact
we've had oh we're good
hi I'm tashana I'm 29.
um I'm single uh currently talking to
someone and a fun fact about me
um I can sing what do you expect this
close to the mic as well I think it's a
bit distant yeah that's all right yeah
thank you
hi my name is Christine I'm 22 in a
relationship a fun fact about me
I'm going to see Slipknot next month
nice because not strike me as a slipknot
fan yeah
hi my name is Nathaniel also known as
nighty ranks I'm 28 and a fun fact about
me is
um I'm a dick on a solar come I'm an
expert at Dean
hey I'm Wayne Elaine I'm 33 years old
pick up the 1990s come on and
um bisexual the best thing ever okay
uh my name is Daniel Frank everyone
calls me Franklin I'm 26 years old uh my
relationship status I'm recently engaged
actually so cool on that thank you thank
you very much uh fun fact about me in
the Philippines I'm a celebrity
yeah
tacos
so I have a question you said you're
bisexual indeed all right can I ask you
questions go for it um they always say
that a guy can't be bisexual that he's
only gay have you heard that before
never heard that and I guess and I tell
you this the women I've been with
wouldn't say that either they wouldn't
does it like put off girls at all
yeah so men find a turn on women are
like intrigued because they're like oh
they asked the question to me again they
go are you sure you're bisexual and I'm
like I'm definitely sure tell me about
the differences between dating men and
dating women men are liars and men will
tell you what they want to tell you to
men are men will tell you what they want
to tell you
which most of the time is just uh
to get into a situation wherever it's
bad or whether it's a date or whatever
do men have to lie to other men to get
something I feel like they do
you know where you stand like if you've
done something wrong they let you know
you they don't need to say anything
they're body language or expression the
way they carry theirselves like you know
you've messed up with a guy
like they'll try and like play it off
so like for me
um yeah I I'm still I'm still trying to
like figure the whole thing out I've
been I mean like I know I was bi since I
was eight and I've been like dating guys
or whatever the last four or five years
but majority of my life is being with
females so I understand females to a t
to a guy I'm just like sometimes I meet
a guy and I'm just like huh I thought I
had it figured and I still don't have it
figured oh who's more of a player men or
women
men men now I'm at a stage where I'm
like now I understand why women be out
there like oh you guys be playing
because it's like it's it's a it's a
crazy world we're gonna give you the
same advice that we give to all these
women
I wonder I wonder if men like if in in
same-sex relationships like
because women we know are hypergamous
I'm like I wonder is it the same like is
it the same like
when it's same-sex are you guys all
sleeping with the same man or is it more
okay I'm very particular okay so some
guys
I've been told sometimes I'm not gay
enough where I'm just a Pacific person
who like what I like and I think it's
come to a point where like I'm 33 years
old I'm like confident who I am and
everyone knows and blah blah blah where
I'm just like it's not just about how
you look or whatever it's actual the
conversation the attraction the the the
overall how you are as an individual
like I've been with people who I
physically wouldn't have been attracted
to but I've gotten to know them and it's
been like you've wowed my mind and that
I find
um sexy and I find it
um yeah and attractive is that the same
for women
both okay it's it's both because I don't
hear guys say that often where they can
like they don't find a girl attractive
and she can like talk her way into being
attracted but I hear I hear women say
that about men that's why it's
interesting yeah it is is I've I've
fallen for a person a female who
um I just used to hang out with and I
physically wouldn't have normally found
her attractive but after going out with
her on just as a friendship thing I
found myself not falling in love with
her but Falling for her and seeing her
in different light
so you were basically the the gay best
friend that they need to worry about
because her boyfriend
um sorry as uh I was I've been this guy
where people where guys that stop their
girls being friends with me yeah because
they're like oh blah blah blah I'm like
but your man knows I'm gay they say of
Gator he's like no he knows you're
buying so it's like it could go both
ways and I've been like just tell him
I'm not by anymore just say I've seen
the light and I've gone all the way gay
honestly and it don't work if I was the
boy for another situation I'm on the
same Vibe
basically as a bisexual I'm just a lover
of all people so just allow me to hang
out with your girls
[Laughter]
would you guys let your girlfriend hang
out with a guy that was by now you know
what because because he's you're able to
kind of
tap into that emotional side yeah on
that side and then you're able to
do whatever lay whatever you need to lay
in it so yeah I'm a good guy
no but you but you know you'll be under
the same category it's just a male best
friend yeah it's not it's not like
sometimes a gay best friend kind of gets
a little black yeah but it's like he
ain't interested in that's What Makes
You scary because you've got all the
attributes of the gay best friend but at
the same time on some days you're not
that gay best friend you know what I
mean
you know what I mean
um okay so today's topic is um talking
about social media and how it pertains
to relationships
um so I want to hear from the women
um on a given day how many messages do
you receive from men interested in you
hmm
okay that's not an answer sorry and when
I put stories up yeah I'll get a couple
of fair few messages to be fair okay so
how many a day like
maybe like three four five okay so five
a day so
um
so go ahead I think for me
um I don't post every day and any sort
of like love or attention that I receive
from dudes is from guys I already know
or have already like had an encounter
with like met before so I don't really
get strangers like hey like what's up
like I don't really get that often but
people that I know will will show me
love okay so how many messages do you
get a day from Ben
like zero okay so you get no messages
from guys interested in you do you have
a public Instagram yes yes but I don't
post often and when I do it's the people
that already know me I really get and if
I do is from like an uncle that's like
25 years older than me then I'm going to
ignore it's like once in a blue moon
uh what about you
I don't really see them come up as much
because they go into message requests
let's say on average between maybe one
two one to two hey guys
how many how many messages do you get a
day you know what it's about when you
post if I post because I'm on my
personal trainer so if I post like a um
update from like my gym progress
then I'll get a flurry of people I might
get up
20 to 25 but on a normal day
if you post you get only if you don't
post it if I don't yeah if you're
beating the women yeah
I don't know so you get more DMS than
the girls I guess so well you know what
would you say is the quality of the
girls that DM you
um like out of every 10 what percent are
you would actually yeah maybe that ten
percent okay it's not ten percent I mean
if I post it if I was to post a trap it
maybe be that forty percent okay I just
don't average sometimes you know I might
I might get some wins in there
[Music]
but no no but yeah usually just yeah
about 10 percent honestly okay yeah
because the gays love is
[Music]
yeah
um so my account is no longer public
I've made it private and the reason why
is because
women are lovely because women were just
like and then be like oh I love like how
positive you are and blah blah blah on
social media guys are very different
there's no I don't think I think there's
a shortage of like masculine mandam as
they call it guys
so I made my account private because
guys have kept dming me
through like and then so like let's say
for example the black gay community in
London is not that big including like
mixed race guys so kind of everyone's
following everyone so some people will
see so some people would see that I'm
following them or blah blah blah and
then and my biography says like
open-minded blah blah blah I don't even
say I'm bisexual so they'll slide in my
DMs
um and then one thing is with guys is
guys okay perfect example
I met a guy who Reviving blah blah blah
weren't really too sure if I liked him
or whatever and he was like look I
wouldn't mind if you had an affair with
a woman because she can give you
something that I can't give you but if
it was with another man
he would find it offensive so how many
messages do you get a day
I can't say in a day I could say I could
get like two three a week two three a
week yeah okay what about you uh I don't
get no message I don't get no messages
that's half the deal with the fact that
I don't really I don't use social media
even when but at the same time back when
I was single
I still didn't really get messages like
that it was you having to fish rather
than the fish coming to you type of
situation not to say that women are
fishing
taking off the flat for boys like
yeah it's like you have to go there
rather than them come here which is very
different to a lot
the other situation I've heard from like
other guys I never got as well because
the guys ratio is very different because
a lot of girls that I've seen get a lot
more messages than a lot of guys have
seen however the guys that do get
messages get a lot and a lot of them
so you have that like one friend that
one male friend who's a 10 out of 10 who
would get 10 times more messages than
any girl however like a bell curve
situation there are more girls getting
more messages than guys right but from
what I've seen
the hottest guys wolves because it goes
to her how pergament so they want to go
for them but the best the best so if
you've got that one guy who's a 10 he's
going to get more messages than any girl
in any room in anywhere because everyone
every girl wants him
so when you guys are looking at a social
media profile um I know some of you are
in relationships but just like think
back to when you're single and you got
you looked at a profile and you had to
decide whether you would respond or not
what would you look at I look at the
fashion and what he's wearing okay so
fashion yeah yeah are you trying to see
how tall he is is that a big thing for
you I mean everyone wants someone over
six foot but I've been with guys that
are smaller than that so it doesn't
really bother me too too much to be fair
but yeah definitely fashion style what
they do okay I think pick up on
personality okay
um also guys if you want anyone to rate
your Instagrams put it in the chat and
we'll see what they think of it
okay so fashion
um you said you want to see what he does
yeah uh what else anything else is that
not if he travels stuff like that in
this traveling house well it just shows
that he probably spontaneous and that's
an adventure yeah
um okay go ahead I think for me
um of course yeah we want to look we
want to see what he looks like so I just
want to see if I like his face you know
um his build I am looking at Fashion I'm
looking at things that's like is he
posing with his like with his top out
like is he trying to show off the perks
like I'm trying to see if he's trying to
flaunt all of that because I'm attracted
to a dude that's confident but I also
don't want someone that's like cocky or
that like likes to put that on display
so if you see like a shirtless picture
is that a turn on or turn off it depends
on like most of the time it's a turn off
but also depends on like how he's posing
like sometimes you can just see some
guys on their profile and they're like
giving you the eyes like smiles and
they're like doing the most and I feel
like that's low-key a bit of a turn off
for me okay
um but yeah I'm looking at like his
friends if he's posted any pictures of
his like Mom if like like Woody does
um yeah I'm just kind of looking at all
of that I don't know if that makes sense
but and what about you
I think for me it's just like if they
post their interest I don't
it more depends on the message for me
rather than the profile because the
profile's fake anyway like everyone's
Instagram is just a fake version of
themselves so it it would catch my eye
if they have something that they're
really passionate and interested in that
they post about that might entice me
more to reply but I think it more
depends on the message for me what type
of message would be a good message to
send you if it can make me laugh or
something funny something funny uh or
something that would make me think like
if they said something really
interesting
[Music]
the standards are rough because it's
like I don't know what you find funny
and not funny
but that's kind of my point like it's
it's it's Instagram like it's it's all a
fake World anyway so you might as well
just give it a go and you know you never
know you've got to have that Universal
risk I mean
what about you two um good first message
to send you
to be fair it depends whether they're
good looking or not if I reply like the
message could just be hey and if it's
good looking I'll entertain it a little
bit but if the conversation's just dead
then it just spoils it
yeah for me like in the past I've had
guys that will like talk about my body
or anything like that and I don't want
to feel like I'm being sexually
objectified in any way so if he comes in
straight off the bat like oh like and
starts talking about my body I'm gonna
ignore that I'm not gonna give her any
energy I'm not too fussy but just saying
hey like how are you and just starting
up a conversation because I'm a human
being so it's like respect me talk to me
like I'm a human being I don't want you
to be on Instagram you know I don't
really post pictures that are like
sexually like provocative or anything
like that too tough I can but like I try
not to do that too can we see it yeah
[Laughter]
um I want to see if we could we look at
your yeah yeah that's fine uh is tashana
talks so
t-a-s-h-a-u-n-a talks because I was kind
of wanted to see I want to get the guys
feedback and like what they would think
of you without meeting you okay
um did you get that blessing
okay
um so you said it just matters how good
looking he is yeah first message for you
as long as it's not sexual yeah just
like say hey like what's up that's fine
did you have something you want to say
yeah I'm the same like if it's sexual I
won't respond whatsoever yeah
have you guys found that that if you
send like a sexual message first it's
like a lower response rate no sorry can
you repeat yeah I think I think um
please oh yeah tashana talks uh
t-a-s-h-a-u-n-a uh t a l k s or one word
yeah but hey hi how are you doing never
works
you get left on red most times you go
just you gotta just start conversation
yeah I mean like people the great thing
about Instagram which is better I think
than um text and get grabbing a number I
remember four people used to be a bit
annoyed if you know you go to talk to a
girl and she gives you like her socials
but the great thing about that is she
posts on there every day so that's
something that you can kind of connect
on at some point you know I mean wait
for that moment where you can kind of
connect on something and then just talk
normally you know I mean don't put
someone on a pedestal in the moment
you've done that yeah the game but were
you guys saying that if you send a
sexual message you're more likely to get
a response
obviously don't go don't go don't go 10
out of 10 games
like complimenting her body or something
like I mean I think there's certain
there's certain profiles that that works
within the same profiles that I wouldn't
yeah because from a guy
for everyone but it's one of those ones
because you guys said all right if you
listen blah blah blah and if if he looks
like he treats me nice but guys do you
think she'll respond
yeah all right so I want to hear from
the guy oh yeah oh put me on blast yeah
yeah so what are we
but we're getting from here traveling
traveling okay coming to Disneyland
there was no commentary
okay so I'm not seeing too much like
skin out yeah I haven't seen any
football posing where the better yet
yeah so she's a respectable girl she's
cute
she's cheating
um I don't really think this is a page
where she's like looking for
yeah she just kind of just enjoying life
I used to work around there cheers
[Laughter]
yeah I wouldn't get uh message her
because she could be a quick one type of
message if I was to see this Instagram
yeah this is a honest individual who is
showing you situations and I like that
in my life that first one that first one
is like don't look at me but look at me
with the whole jacket
what's your Instagram he's gonna pull it
out it's Ashton Maria
[Laughter]
yeah we have one girl on this show we
did a show today called wife or cat lady
yeah yeah you come on the show and we
had we had one percent men so all these
men were verified Millionaires and they
all had to um decide if the women coming
in were wife wifey or cat ladies you
know and this one girl that came in
it was like her boobs were like oh it
was like a see-through like top on
Instagram yeah and I was trying to tell
her I'm like I don't know if that's like
what the the millionaire maybe like the
millionaire like Ballers maybe that's a
different group but like I'm like I
don't know about the millionaire like
businessman you know
but yeah she didn't get it
yeah well she was very she was very
beautiful oh see she didn't need to do
that yeah no that's what I was telling
her because I was like I was like I
probably would have put her top like 10
20 of beauty she's so beautiful and I
was just like why would you put that
like yeah no need I was like that's like
being born 6 10. yeah and not playing
basketball
and bowling
that's that's interesting she needs more
people around I just said tell her that
she's attractive in the face yeah I told
her she could come back
um if she deleted three of these
pictures on Instagram
she was attached to the Instagram okay
she was a very nice girl but I was like
you're very attached to the insta
she's comparing herself to whoever she
idolizes on there so she might see
someone remember that all comes down to
self-confidence no but not but there
might be a woman that she finds she
might look at cardi B and think raw if I
was if I was like if I was inside girls
I'm under you know what I mean so she
kind of just wants to mimic that and she
thinks that that is gonna get her what
she needs in it you know what I mean do
you find it weird that like a lot of
girls speaking again this is a very
general statement but a lot of girls in
that kind of respect will look at idols
and and mimic what they look like but a
lot of guys will look at their idols and
mimic what they act like and do
um right but we focus more on respect
and I think with women sometimes could
be more of an attention visual because
how many people have cardi b as their
role model JLo
exactly 53 years
[Music]
who their role model is it's like Samuel
Jackson or something I was trying to
think of one good feminine role model in
the media today yeah like that's in Main
Street
is that
Jayla she's a role model for me she's a
like she does like YouTube videos okay
but she's not like anywhere near as big
as someone like Beyonce or cardi B just
pearly things
[Laughter]
uh do you want to pull up the Instagram
you thought you escaped
oh no no no no no okay what are we
thinking
so then of course she gets a point
because she was on my podcast
this picture here
this is interesting runs you know what's
really important the captions
you see that picture another adventure
okay that one looks proper that picture
would make a bisexual straight again is
that coming on your stuff you're sick
you know
all right all right she's cool let me
see what she say uh
what type of message would you guys send
as an opener to her
uh it'll be it'll be you know with me
I'm not trying to give too much away but
it'll be usually be Story related
something related to whatever you're
posting that right now what Adventure do
you want to go in there
if you posted like back in July last
year like you went somewhere and then
you don't really want to talk about that
right now if you're in Dubai right now
or you're somewhere we can talk about
that maybe you know but going through
her page I normally the pictures are uh
a given but I like I like to look at
their statuses as well what they're
captioning the things you know what I
mean yeah the single eyes do like
because it's one of those one Pages
where you're like okay you see enough
in the pictures to be like okay if I was
to message this person like I said
before when guys message like will she
respond she might she might depending on
what you say right so what your
Instagram gives off you have to come
with like really a student you have to
be really on your stuff with yours
you're like what type of person would
you have thought she was before probably
seen in the nightclubs out there and
stuff I've seen you out I haven't but
yeah what are you in the nightclubs or
no I used to a lot when I was younger
but now it's more events like bars stuff
like that I don't really go out to the
clubs too too much certified nights yeah
cocktail bars two for one before seven
yeah okay I know I've seen you before
do any of the guys want to volunteer
their Instagrams let's do it man
all the message you've ever sent to a
girl oh
um what the ones that you have to send a
message and put your phone down and look
away
like a wild person oh first message oh
no don't I don't need to know
probably like a uh probably you know I
think if if she's abroad you get a
little bit more confidence in it
when you're gonna quit playing and just
move to London you know what I mean
those kind of ones
sometimes I would do funny ones that are
only funny to me like I can see you
that's the message
[Laughter]
was funny I've never dm'd anyone before
they've DM me sorry
no I didn't I didn't know it was a thing
I didn't know it was a thing
called and then I just kind of react
what's in the vibe of it what's your
back signal with you like a couple
pictures you like the story so if I like
your pictures more than one okay you
know what it means then he knows what
time if you don't he or she let's go
fully gay okay
and then we and then we kind of then
every sleeve you get a private message
or something like that then I kind of
react to that where it's a female or a
male but a female is very different
where
I'm very it's very different with a
female because I'm kind of more romantic
type so I'm a face-to-face person anyway
I'm old school like pretend social media
didn't didn't exist so with a female
it'd be like let's let's go catch a bite
let's go to a cocktail but and I think
as time go on
I'm kind of the same thing with guys
it's not just a thing where I just want
to talk anyone can be anyone on social
media or on the phone I want to feel
your Vibe by the way you talk the way
you hold yourself as a person your body
language and and that's it because
that's what Wows me and that's what gets
here and if you've got me here yeah so
if you're a little female you've got me
and you obviously know like when uh what
kind of girls or guys to that you need
to take on a date and you know which
which ones you can just bring back
like what guys are different though yeah
because guys
are there any like tests you guys do to
see how [__] a girl is
uh yeah yeah yeah if you say the word
this should be outdated now someone
throw this out there but you know if if
he if he says uh trouble and you can
spot in a certain type of way it's game
over for you it's there you guys know
that if he says all trouble and you're
like
trouble no no no just just ignore the
whole trouble thing in it because I
think you guys be using trouble yeah
it's kind of the same Vibe of um if I
hear the words come out my mouth that's
just who I am you know that girl is
topped
what do you mean because anytime you
hear that people just don't understand
who I am that person is someone who
argues for fun that's someone who who
light your car on fire because you told
her that you were too pants off that
someone
that's someone that will have a fight
with you because their cousins were
upset of you what do you think about the
the girls that say that they just get
along with guys more than girls
seeing for me
for me that's interesting coming from
you
[Laughter]
I need you just with me okay just with
me about people's girlfriends no that's
cool
I'm a good guy you're giving Vibes as
you can't have friends what other tests
you guys do
um I kind of just look out I just I just
observe man you gotta observe like
people were telling themselves
eventually so you just observe what kind
of stuff they're posting if they're
posting a lot of like indirect quotes to
that means that they need to heal
[Music]
[Laughter]
I'm girl or female and they told me
that's come out relationship yeah I'm
not I'm not fussed with you but if we're
just talking on a sexual situation
I have needs okay but if it's something
where you want it to go like in a
relationship or whatever you need you
need time to help maybe it's just you
just want to have fun or whatever then
yeah I can't take you seriously if you
told me you just broke up with your
partner to your point or whatever a few
weeks ago I can't take you seriously if
she posts 100 quotes then you're right
she does have a hundred issues that she
needs to sort out or something at some
point there's a specific page yeah
the one that begins with a J and it's in
a y like that one if they post that yeah
red flag Trinidad do you guys look at
who girls follow sometimes yeah you have
to sometimes because you know I don't do
that they follow Sam Smith
do you guys look at who guys follow
no no if I'm interested yeah I'll go
through who they follow and what if he
follows a bunch of Instagram models does
that bother you
not really because guys are going to be
guys aren't they they're all going to be
attracted to like Instagram models but
it doesn't really bother me too too much
to be fair so what do you look for when
it comes to their following
um
we'll say if like a girl's like
commented on their page I'll go I'll go
through that pacific girl if that makes
sense oh okay yeah interesting
I care about the mutual oh damn yeah
yeah I need to know which one of my
friends
if we're mutual friends yeah I know why
he knows
it's crazy because I trust women I don't
I don't whenever I'm dating a girl
talking to a girl I don't do any
research on you whatsoever it's the guys
that I know are just over there in the
streets guys are completely different
guys are the one I'm just like I watch
your mutuals that's interesting because
everyone in London like guy wise in the
whole game will be sleeping with
everyone the women yeah I don't know man
with women I kind of just trust you I
don't I don't think I've ever had a girl
play out on me I the younger version of
me like okay for example I think any guy
that's under the age of 25 or like 20
years old if they've cheated
sorry I know you're going to disagree
with me like it's not really a cheat
we're not a man we don't really know
what we're doing
um so I think like if you're under the
age of 25 and you cheat look at you
looking at me
we're under 25 and I've done it and I
think a lot of us have done it
um I don't think it's for yourself
what I'm trying to say is I think if a
woman takes a guy seriously under the
age of 21 and he's cheated that's on you
because we're not our mentality women to
me mature far more than men at a
different who's right who's more
childish men or women men there's men
that saw like 40 50s through playing
PlayStations with
um generally speaking with women that
have kids yeah I feel like they they
learn a certain sense of responsibility
and that no one's coming to save them
yeah yeah I mean up until then I think
they can be a bit childish in in society
they're playing a step down I don't
actually think that men are more mature
than women I don't think no I think men
are more
[Music]
you know
um my there's this saying that's like
right when a woman starts to receive
attention from men she like doesn't age
mentally so like she's like whatever age
it was so 13 14 15. and I went out and I
had this like red pill moment a couple
years ago my mom I got in trouble in
high school so she sent me to my
grandma's house and I was at um and it
was weird because a lot of um the
grandmas were like widows right so their
grandmas all went like to this like
karaoke bar and it's like a weird small
town and the way they were talking I was
like this sounds like me and my friends
and we're like 14 15.
um but I I think like in the media they
always paint women as the Smart Ones and
men as the dumb ones and I think that
like if you think of The Simpsons it's
always you know Marge is smart Bard is
dumb yeah
Family Guy this is the fat guy that
can't be trusted with anything I think
like in general women play way more
childish games than men do but women are
a lot smarter and a lot smarter same
thing like when women cheat because
women cheats
manipulatives all right men we're not
that good like women would do smart
thing my ex my ex-partner used to do
stuff like when I was sleeping would
just do the fingerprint thing and go
through my messages that's a smart thing
to do and she knows I'm a deep sleeper
and go through my eyes
we as men we ain't we ain't we ain't
really trying to do that because I think
that question is very it's a very
nuanced question because there was there
were a lot of areas in society where
women are like a lot more mature than
men internally like when it comes like
emotional like had to do with one's
emotions women have got that passed
since day one because that's literally
most of what they're doing from I
disagree what women love emotions
women women are in control of them I
didn't say in control I said I said no I
didn't say get down I just said have the
ability to look at their emotions and be
one with their emotions accept it yeah
accept it I'm not saying
yeah but like the fact that women have
gone through this emotional turmoil when
they go through all the time and like if
they see a dog dies is this like the
worst thing in the world
have you guys ever gone through a guy's
phone
[Laughter]
um why'd you go through his phone
because I knew he was doing something
doji yeah I wouldn't do it unless I had
a suspicion
um and I had a suspicion and I was right
and every time I've done it I've been
right
what'd you find but now I've got to a
point where I will never do it because
every time I've done it I've found
something and I actually really like my
boyfriend so I like even if I get the
feeling I'm like I don't want problems
just leave it at this point
but what did you find uh naked pictures
from other girls oh wow yeah he was but
like how I used to get her all the time
my ex-girlfriend like girlfriends have
had have gone one Pacific partner has
gone through my phone and woke me up at
like three in the morning been like oh
blah blah blah I'm like but how did you
know and I've been I don't know I don't
know
continuous but my younger days
like I would just be like but how did
you even know I was talking to her on
Facebook or how did you know well I
couldn't answer that one what what made
you think a woman always knows I'm like
what is this
there's a lot of subconscious things
that you would do yeah okay so it's like
we we pick up on little social cues that
like men don't right so like okay we'll
see
it well we'll notice let's say if you
don't like text us around the time you
normally text us yeah or like or if you
don't do something you normally do that
you wouldn't like think anything of like
women we noticed yeah we notice
everything or if like you have a certain
interaction with a girl and you think
well that's how we used to interact with
me yeah I liked when we first met
because the thing is the thing is guys
have this as well and guys you know the
whole the whole thing of like guys
knowing who that one guy friend who's
actually trying to [__] guys also see
this as well so we understand it's just
very it's kind of different how we go
about dealing with it so guys we'll go
go around be like oh that one friend
we'll just say it directly because guys
are way more direct than women we're
like yo that friend Zeke or whatever his
name is Zach or I'm trying to think of
random names oh Zach's trying to [__]
you like there's gonna be no ones where
guys will tell their girlfriend I don't
know always
a girl will do we'll look at the same
information and instead of just saying
outright like you know Sarah was trying
to have sex with you bro it'll be like
they'll they'll go around and like get
you to see it through their words type
of thing you know what I mean there's
very different approaches that guys the
approach that we take sometimes as guys
is like we think that that's going to
repulse the girl they go like sex bro
and she likes to the attention if you
say you know you know that male friend
he wants to [__] you know what he wants
to [__]
is she gonna just see my blood oh is it
you know I mean she probably knows
already but you know at the end of the
day that's why I feel like with male
friends
um with women and and guys like having
that friendship is very much um it works
in a woman's favor a lot of the time so
you wouldn't let me be friends with your
girl
no you you know
we're good bro we're good but but I
would I would treat you like a male
friend that she has in it so the
boundaries will be there ain't no let's
get changed together you can't come in
one day and you're in there change all
right listen to this yeah I once had a
girl or she she wanted to come around my
yard and and work or something and she
was like oh a boyfriend won't allow it
because it's just me and her I was like
but why though just me and her she's
working from instead of working from
home it's about not putting her so her
boyfriend said no yeah it's about her
not being in a space or in a situation
where something could happen there
should be boundaries in place if you're
in a relationship there's a friend of
mine she's a good friend she was a good
friend of mine yeah but like put like
this I was in a situation where I hope
to go do her assignment but by the end
of the night did we finish the
assignment no
you finished another thing because the
situated like one-on-one in those type
of situations and those type of times I
can 100 understand that the guy being
like Oh yeah I feel a bit away you think
your face you were even scheming I could
see you when is that guy that cheats on
you and then he will say no it was 425
no you have the Amanda will be like oh
my girl trying to say I was cheating on
her and I'm like yeah but bro
like wait it's us it's awesome
you just don't want to put yourself in a
situation where something could come
back let's say the girl lies and you
can't really defend yourself it's her
word against yours I think that there
should be boundaries in place like I
don't think it's okay if you are if
she's in a relationship it's not okay
for her to be bopping up to your room to
work like why I don't understand there's
no but you're just chilling you're
working from home you usually work from
home did you when she said that to you
did you say you know I understand that's
a really like that's great your
boyfriend had boundaries or did you say
oh that's horrible I said to her but he
knows I'm by though this doesn't help
I've even not been intimate before we we
no we haven't we got in a situation
where I knew she had feelings for me
[Laughter]
trust me
[Music]
okay I want to know if if you got I know
you're not single but when you were
single if you guys would respond or not
and what you would think of him
you know I can't really see is that your
car I feel like if I saw this Instagram
I would think probably that's the one
that the game is
yeah
but I don't think this is I don't need
this type of problem you've got blue
ticks coming into yours as well wow you
see this
oh yeah definitely yeah yeah yeah is
that Magnum
okay uh would you guys what do you guys
think what would you like the last
picture in this picture is fine there
was a couple pictures I would be like um
yeah
so would you guys respond
yeah probably yeah yeah what about you
two would you respond no
I don't know I think you're a good
looking guy but
I don't know because of course you had
your you were flexing
someone getting some glasses
no yeah no I mean you're a good looking
guy but I think yeah there was a couple
of pictures that I'm
um
it's just yeah something I well yeah
but it's I mean I think I have that view
in general though like even if a girl is
like and I'm not gonna say I haven't
done this in the past but if you're out
there like bikini like tits like tits in
the camera like showing off your body in
a certain type of way you want a certain
type of attention like I can't take you
seriously
I agree
I just I'm like I would think
because when you see a profile like that
I would just assume you get so much
attention yeah you're saying it's true
and so I'm like I'm not a headache no
I'm too jealous
you know I mean you're a demon
[Music]
um have you guys ever went through a
girl's phone yeah I mean businesses do
audits right
damn
what did you find did you find anything
most of the time um you know guys a
little bit we're just we don't go for
the right things I think women know
exactly where to look guys gonna look
for random [__] yeah
I'll be honest though
um I think once once you're in that
place where it becomes a thing where you
need to
then um and it's different like someone
going someone opening up your phone when
your sleep is different to like someone
leaving you with their phone and then
you might just you know okay that pop-up
came up what was that what was that yeah
yeah yeah it's a bit of a difference if
you're like waking people up or like
trying to do all that kind of stuff I
think there's there's other problems
there I think sometimes there's a
curiosity thing where that people have
where it's just open and you just you
might just all that because there's even
times where I'll put it down to someone
being on their phone next to you and how
many times like let's say someone's
typing their password in front of you
how many times do money want to be guys
so we do this
okay you know what I mean but we do that
because your woman will look at it easy
but you know guys you want to feel
secure so you're just like no I'm not
even gonna look because you don't want
problems in it but sometimes you you
just look and see uh cool what's going
on everything cool all right cool you
know I mean yeah I don't I haven't
checked in the same way of like being
that one like person who's very worried
and have to check through the phone the
check-in checking phone quote is one of
those ones like you said you're on her
phone you're playing [__] Fruit Ninja
or whatever and like a text comes up you
know
it's your private space but you see the
name and you see with the messages and
you're like okay you just keep a mental
note all right I think yeah if you don't
trust your partner then I think
life is life is too short for me to go
through your phone it's like why am I
even with you I think for me there's a
question from the chat
um they want to know from the girls
is cheating what which would you prefer
um you go through his phone and you find
him he has naked pictures from another
girl
or he was buying her things but there is
nothing physical
it's both cheating why is he buying yeah
that's not the question you gotta pick
one
um
oh that's difficult
I think
I think I think naked pictures is
definitely worse okay I think yeah so if
he bought her a bunch of clothes or
something that wouldn't be as bad as
naked pictures yeah yeah I'm the same to
make the pictures worse no I have to
disagree because
what
let's be real some of the stuff that
girls post on Instagram
does it really make a difference if
you're sending nudes privately on
Snapchat or if you're just posting that
on Instagram like you're gonna have
people
doing what they do I agree with you I'm
like I think it's more personal if I
found out dude was buying some random
Instagram grow a bunch of [__] I'd be
like
what that's a whole mind [__] like the
nudes it's like okay a man's a man a man
has penis like he's gonna do what he's
gonna do but it's like the buying things
it's like
that's the effort and is it yeah is it
different than like corn do you know
what I mean like if a guy gets a picture
from a girl yeah versus looks up corn
online is it that big how much
difference yeah yeah exactly because
it's all just like
I mean it's just flesh but like the act
of buying
someone a gift takes thought and effort
like a guy getting nudes he's getting
that for one thing yeah but it's also
about to give attention the intentions
of why he's buying her something as well
like he's probably buying her something
so that he can sleep with her eventually
I know but you know
yeah he's emotionally would you guys
break up if zero contact happened
yeah yeah
because you know what's funny when you
ask that first question we gave each
other a look we gave each other a look
because we both know if you buying
someone else a gift yeah that is what
I'm trying to cheat he's trying to I
mean he's really having a conversation
he's looking to have a conversation with
his girl and he's like he's talking to
her enough that he knows her well enough
to think that he can buy her things and
know what she likes that means he's been
talking to her for a while which means
he's he's down to book a ticket if he
drops to the address no that's that's
the difference between like like a fling
an affair yeah a fair is you know he
follows
fling is any news you're gonna find or
whatever the news is whatever because
you can if he's a cheater he can be
getting news from 11 people whatever if
he's like a Serial then he's getting
news from everyone but if he's sending
if he's got to a point of messaging this
person to a point where he's sending a
gifts on a somewhat regular basis what
about only fan subscription if you found
it
that would turn me off myself
can be used in different ways though
because there's people that do only fans
that don't you don't need to fully do
the whole does he wait he he's
subscribed to one right that's what
you're saying
it's like sad like I don't know I'd
almost rather he cheat than subscribe
[Laughter]
and then I would wonder I'm like did I
do something wrong
I've had this conversation no it's the
same with like um like maybe escorts and
stuff in it so let's say for instance
we've only found is it makes it more
personal so let's say you could have
only funds that you don't probably but
if you do and someone really wanted they
couldn't really bother to wine and
Daniel or talk to with you like that but
they really were like
sexually attracted to you they could
just go through the only funds pay that
little subscription see everything in in
their head you're a body now yeah
they've you know I mean you know I've
done whatever and then they can go on
with their life you know what I'm saying
same thing with like escorts or whatever
instead of doing a whole day in
situation they paid for escort they've
got the system and they've moved on so
it's like I think with only fans the
only difference between only fans and
PornHub
is that they have
um they might know the person
they might know who the person is it's
within reach that's why I think only
fans is growing because it's more
personal you ain't got to do nothing
though you know you know there's people
like there's female escort yeah the guy
with like all the guys
same thing with only fans like you
haven't got to sexually do anything
never go through a girl's phone if you
believe that you need to go through her
phone all you're doing is looking for
anything to confirm what you already
believe is happening
um sorry but that is true only that's a
violation
okay because I would genuinely look at
myself and say what did I do
to do like like that he has to pay he
can't just go inside because pain pain
for born in 2020 corn so for 20 in 2023
is wild in and of itself but it's the
same I agree it's the same as a date so
remember this remember this a lot of
people it's the fault of having
something that they can't have and it's
an attraction where everything
I mean that's a sexual that's a sexual
drive because I can't I'm not physically
having you you're just someone that's on
the computer screen it's same thing like
we're an affair a lot of people and
Affair is sexy and and they love it and
there's an attraction until it becomes
something that's like allowed you know
like people leave their wives for their
mistress
and they're like all of a sudden it's
like it's not as fun anymore it's not
the same we all want something that you
can't happen often mistress
by the wife and end up with the mistress
but you don't leave the web for the
mistress you're a dummy in that
situation yeah
you're a dumbass
has social media ever caused an argument
in a relationship yeah oh my God yeah
what if women argued with you or men
about uh the liking game but back when
that was a feature
discussions all the time but I would I
was like I would do it for like
algorithm things so if I know I'm about
to post I'll just like anything on my
timeline because I know they're gonna
look and they're gonna go and like my
thing back yeah that was that that was
the vibe I would like picture of your
grand your uncle whatever dogs anything
on that timeline at that time I'll just
I'll just think I know be next to me
what I'll do it it's not like I have to
do it in secret but I understand it
looks crazy yeah it looks crazy anything
you pop because as well it puts it onto
the news feed as well remember when you
can see whatever people that's what I'm
talking about
so I used to get into into situations
about that but I think on the flip side
if your girl only follows 90 people
let's say for instance and then and I
you know I mean and then she follows
that one guy you're gonna be you might
have ec91
what is that yeah
I haven't been there yeah so I think it
works both ways though what have you
gotten into art my situation was
different where
um a girl slid into my DMs on Facebook I
like went the extra mile on Facebook to
find out that she went college with my
girl
and then how that went was Facebook you
know like when your relationship it says
your relationship with this person I
wasn't that smart when I was below 25
like I said
um so what happened was
um she was like oh when we started out
in the conversation she was like oh but
you're in a relationship with this
person hold on a minute I think I went
to the same College oh I did go to the
same college she screenshotted my whole
conversation with the girl and sent it
to my uh my then girlfriend man and that
obviously cool that argument is because
you were cheating yeah
um it's essentially like you said it's
one of those like back when you can see
who you liked and what you liked back
when there was a thing is like it was
you with like back back then again we
were young we were dumb we didn't know
where the social media was we grew up
with social media essentially at the
same time so you would see your partner
liking all these things and then that
would be an argument because
for those who don't know who are too
young to know Instagram means to show
people who you liked like like the
pictures you liked on like his own
separate feed so that feed will get you
girls know this yeah that feed will get
you in trouble did you know that um I'm
not sure if it's the same now but before
on Instagram if you were following under
200 people it wouldn't show what order
you followed people in did you know that
so like let's say your man goes out on a
night out and he starts following
someone new then you know
I don't know if it's still the same
feature in I don't know P updates and
stuff but yeah man those kind of things
get into you get into arguments over
there wait let me ask you something
right because what you just said bro I
weren't cheating it was a conversation
[Music]
is like a physical situation
you can emotionally cheat all right let
me ask you this let me see this because
I don't know I'd like to hear that
coming from women Devil's Advocate is it
really the end of the world if he's
messaging another girl thank you oh like
I I agree it's not the end of the world
I just think like if we have open social
media profiles can we really like get
off our high horse sometimes like
because I think that attention is
um to women as sexist to men do you guys
agree with better yeah okay so I'm like
if we most of us have open Instagrams
and relationships meaning we can get
attention from high status men and
that's always on the table but if he
sends a message like it's the end of the
world no but if he does what he was
doing
she mentioned me first I was just
responding as rude not to respond what
kind of message me talking about if it's
like if it's like you know emojis and
stuff like that and I mean if it's
General conversation then you know yeah
maybe that's a bus case it's crazy look
at things like differently I just no I'm
with you
if you're the type of person to like
date for like a long-term relationship
or marriage right
um then it's like like in the grand
scheme of things there's a message gonna
make or break your life yeah exactly
it's the intention about you know I
think most of it becomes that gray area
of the unknown so it's the attention
behind the message all right let me ask
you a question because I don't feel like
you're on my side I'm not okay all right
you let her on that break yeah
okay
okay it's a single she's single okay so
you might agree with me in this yeah
you've been reach out for a while now I
was a situation okay you have a girl
she's not your girl but you know like
you have not it sounds bad like a backup
not a backup you have people on your
phone that you know like you but now I
was in a situation where I was always
with someone from like 16 so when I
wasn't with someone I used to just grab
a girl that I knew like me because I
wanted to feel like it was a fulfill
thing right so if I'm not with so if I'm
not with you and we've broken up for
like a week and we have a sexual
situation I didn't cheat on you because
we were on a break ain't no random
fingers bro
[Laughter]
no I hear you what I'll see you is um
the moment you are
on a break you've you've fed her to the
Wolves bro you can't and vice versa bro
you're single you're two single people
it's no longer I know it may feel that
you know okay cool we were in a
relationship but
you're not under that Covenant you're
not under that contract that obligation
that verbal commitment anymore in it so
whatever you do it might be frowned upon
it might be whatever but some people
just move on quicker than others that's
all I feel like you're like 20 on my
side now
would you guys work through a message
yeah she would
um
I think no I think the intentions matter
and I think that if he's messaging
somebody else he's already checked out
and I'm I think I'm very strict when it
comes to that like I think that if
you're going to be in a relationship
with me I think that you have to put
some boundaries in place I think yeah
what if you're on holiday and then you
come back and you find that he he
messaged another girl because you were
away I'm leaving him I'll be a few
minutes yeah no no I'm leaving him I
think I I don't tolerate anything but
because to me it seems a bit much to
break up over a message it depends what
the message is though yeah it depends
what the message is the intention's
quite clear how how old are you guys
again you're what I'm 29 29.
[Laughter]
I'm just thinking because you're you're
29 if you're in a relationship like do
you want kids yes um do you don't have
any kids so you know if you're single by
30 your chance of having a child drops
below 50 so you're actually more likely
to not have a kid than have one and by
34 your chance of having like any kids
at all like geriatric pregnancy working
is like nothing it's like yeah I see
it's pretty scary so it's like though
I said I know the good eyes
because I'm assuming you're picky right
uh to find like picky like I think I
have my standards I don't think I ask
for anything too crazy I just want a guy
that's like serious about me has pure
intentions for me and will be loyal well
I'm just thinking because you've been
dating since we're 18 yeah 20. yeah
right 20 okay so like I'm just thinking
of nine years if none of the guys that
approached you you like enough to marry
like you probably pick key oh right
and this is just me like usually that
women that are single over the age like
25. it's not an insult you know no no no
I think to be honest I'm a Christian and
I think that that makes things a bit
harder for me because there's certain
things that I'm like that I want to do
to please God or there's some some views
that I have that are more like biblical
than like the world and I think that now
I used to date guys that were
non-christians but the things that I was
passionate about the values that I had
they didn't share those same values and
I want to be with someone that shares
those same values as me and has the same
world for you as me so now that's kind
of a narrative it's just him being a
Christian no I mean he has to be a
Christian of course but there's just
certain things that like I've realized
are my deal breakers like why are you on
the waiting until marriage type I mean
yeah I'm not I'm not perfect but that's
definitely a desire it's a desire to
want to wait until marriage yeah okay
but you're I'm assuming 29 I'm not a
virgin I'm not a virgin
it's definitely a desire I'm not saying
it won't happen but it's a desire and I
would like to stick to that because I
guess in my head I'm like okay so if
you're 29 you know that by now now you
know at least that if you're single by
next year you're most likely not going
to have a kid
and that by 34 your chance of having a
kid is basically nothing like
biologically so I'm just thinking if you
get into a relationship with a guy that
you like which I'm assuming is very hard
to find a guy that meets all your
criteria because I mean me too it's not
you're not not just you because I'm
thinking like if you get to that point
it's kind of like your last
chance in a way and then you and then
you leave it over what a message
it's like I would think in the grand
scheme of things it would be more
important to have a family to you
especially you know they say like be
fruitful and multiply in the Bible yeah
but I think for me it's also very
important to be in a situation that is
healthy and I would rather be single
than be in a relationship where I'm not
valued or where I'm being disrespected
or where the duties emotionally or
sexually cheating yeah sometimes I just
Church like leaves women single and I
think it's really sad because I think
sometimes they tell women like we have
to have these crazy high standards yeah
yeah I think that the church that's not
the message you know that's not that
crazy but I think the church does need
to do a better job with teaching young
Christians like how to date like I go to
an amazing church and it's I'm learning
now like through I go to the tab London
and my pastor is is amazing and he just
recently done a sermon on dating and
like how to date you know you know for
marriage with the intention of marriage
and it was very healthy and very
informative would would you submit to
your husband for everything
but the thing is like with me choosing a
husband I'm gonna choose somebody that I
respect I'm going to choose somebody
that loves God and for me submission is
about if he submitted submitting to
Christ I'm low-key submitting to Christ
if I'm submitting to my husband so then
why did you say no but it's like to me
submitting I think I need to learn about
that more I'm definitely my own woman
but I think it depends in like in what
degree like in what situation do you
follow the Bible
I try well no it just it confuses me
when like that I become one in the Bible
they say the same thing you have to
submit in the Bible of course I think it
just confuses me like when you say you
want a Christian man but you don't want
to live in a Christian way so like why
would a man that's super Christian want
to be with you if you don't want to live
in a Christian way which is biblical but
what do you mean by not living in a
Christian way so in the Bible says you
have to submit to your husband and when
I asked you you said no yeah but then
and but this is what I'm saying I think
in certain situations I think and how
can I word this in certain situations of
course if the decision that my husband
is making makes sense and that's fine
yeah I don't really know how to just to
explain the thoughts that I'm having
right now you want to submit when you
feel like it
yes
but then the Bible also the thing is the
Bible does instruct women with like how
to act in marriage but then the Bible
also instructs men with how to treat
their wives as well and so like the
Bible says to women like respect your
husbands and husbands love your wives
and so I feel like yeah but how are we
supposed to get a Christian guy if we
can't start with what we have to do yeah
folks you know like yes I'm just I'm
just you know because you want to start
a family yeah so I'm just wondering how
this should work out go ahead is it an
issue of knowing so you said about the
whole decision thing
um which logically makes sense so like
if he's saying something and you don't
I'm just guessing right if he says
something and you don't know why is your
point you want to know why and if it
makes sense to you then you agree and
that's your version of submitting
yeah I think and that's the thing my
thing is I think that a marriage there's
going to be a lot of like complexities
and like a lot of different situations
that we're going to face in marriage
it's going to be a learning curve it's
going to be like a journey and I think
that also with whatever the Bible does
say the Bible also teaches about like
sanctification and about like a journey
of becoming more like Christ so I'm not
saying that I'm perfect but I'm saying
hopefully me and my husband will get to
a point where you know we're on the same
page and I think yeah you don't believe
like going with the flow no no no but
God don't say no because going with the
flow could be the best thing the reason
why I say going with the flow you could
be dating you could be on Tinder
whatever and someone could say what are
you looking for right and I could say
for me as a 33 year old I want a child I
want a child but I don't have a if God
blesses me with a child I get blessed
with a child I'm not religious in any
way shape or form but I believe in in
Almighty my thing right now when I meet
a girl or a guy and they say like what
you're looking for to say look like my
portfolio would say like I want kids
soon blah blah blah but I'll just say
look I'm just here going through the
flow but I'm looking for a a serious
individual and I would elaborate on that
situation but like when I say I'm going
with the flow doesn't mean I want to
marry you or date you I just want to
chill with you and see where things go
so there is no expectations on either
side you know I mean it's just about
getting to know the person getting to
know the person but I feel like if
you're with the whole Christian thing
um hats off to you
um
I feel like for guys it can be a bit
intimidating and we don't know where to
start and we're like oh okay you know
what I mean baby you say like Glenn
others are Super Chat says there's no
exception to submission in the Bible
where it says to only submit to your
husband when you want to it says for
everything because you've got to choose
a man that you trust to lead right and
then you've got to listen to it you've
got to submit to because it's as simple
as that because sometimes you can ask
like at the end of the day if you really
are submitting to your husband you're
trusting that they know what they're
doing they're handling things so any
decision they make you shouldn't even be
questioning it anyway because you should
trust them enough to know that they've
already thought that through so you
don't have to so by asking questions
you're kind of creating problems for him
for having to explain it all through to
you and then also you're potentially
causing another problem by then putting
up a barrier if you don't agree with
something that he's done like to me I
would rather leave him with it he says
we're doing something fine I trust him
enough that he knows what he's doing and
he's doing that for Albertsons look look
at team sports here let's say imagine
Alex Ferguson's your manager and then
he's like cool this player is going to
win off the champions league and when
actually and you got this one brother
that's always always uh nah I'm the
manager yeah I'm here to do a job trust
I'm gonna lead and we'll go if you find
a man that keeps leading you into the
into the darkness then that's not the
man for you I guess in it but you gotta
you gotta be on that journey and
actually accept that call I've chosen
this person I just thought of a question
do you think it it is unbiblical if
women don't have children
the God says to be fruitful and multiply
right and right now women are 100 in
control of who's born so like sex and
reproduction because we're the only ones
that can have a choice in abortion
um and the way the laws are set up like
we're 100 in control so is it unbiblical
if women don't have kids a woman should
be in full control is her buddy and what
she wants to no I'm not I'm not asking a
question like okay
um I can gossip and I'm in full control
if I want to gossip or not but it's
unbiblical of me to gossip I think
anyways I think if a woman can have kids
she should have kids
that's just my opinion yeah so I'm just
yeah it says to be through for
multiplayer so yeah you're right and
also for people who are believers
Christians it is still their
responsibility to go and preach the word
and and do anything to do see this is
this is where I come because I was going
to come to your appointment because I'm
also a Christian right so I I believe in
all the same passages
so for the first because I have two
things for the first thing was to your
point about submission
now as a follow-up question when we say
submit to God does that mean like what
does that mean because then we have to
think about the words that we're using
because we use those words in
Christianity already right when we say
we need to submit to Jesus we submit
submit to God submit to the word of
Christ right
that same submission and the
understanding of what it means to submit
to Christ in that same vein obviously
it's not the same because the person
you're submitted to isn't Jesus I'm not
trying to equate them but it's this very
similar vein of like you wouldn't like
like you like you said you wouldn't
question what's coming next if you were
100 submissive now understanding who to
be submissive to is very very difficult
because there are a lot of Snakes in the
Grass there's a lot of people who show
one thing show one hand and actually are
another like like we were saying before
but the actual Act of to say I would
only submit in a certain in a certain
situation which is not what you said but
it's like what it sounds like sounds
like right don't you think it's I don't
think it's that difficult to be honest
what do you mean like I don't think it's
like we kind of like as women like we
act like there's so many men that are
cheating and doing all this stuff but
most men can't do that yeah it's true
like I think there's a lot of average
guys like as women we can date that
wouldn't actually I don't think it's
that crazy it's it's not but what I'm
saying is in the sense of like I'm I'm
taking it back to the biblical sense of
submission and the submission that God
has told us to do to his people and for
for him and his son Jesus right so we
understand as Christians what submission
is
but when it comes to submission using
submission to man it becomes slightly
different to Jesus yeah I think there's
just been a breakdown in trust but in
the day in the day right now that's what
I'm saying you know what I mean so with
like women don't really trust family
yeah
our Guan says no it's not unbiblical
because there are women who are born
that don't have the ability to have kids
okay
um would you have an issue submitting to
your boss
for you someone asked me
um
yes there has been times with past
managers where I think that they're not
always making the right decision okay
and so but I think that I do believe in
just creating that space that respectful
safe environment where I can voice my
opinions they can voice theirs and then
we can just have that conversation
because I think that even if you're my
boss it doesn't mean that like you can't
take on good advice or like do things in
a different way so I think I think I can
submit but I believe in being vocal do
you know how tiring that is as a boss
though
oh my gosh if I told my editor added the
video this way and every single time I
gave him something he's telling me the
way he wants to do it do you know how
annoying that is no I mean it's not it's
not okay to wear it you've got nothing
done like it's not a case where every
five seconds I've got a problem but
there's just been a couple of situations
in the past I believe in being vocal I
believe in being vocal I believe in
creating that safe space to have a
conversation with the person once
they've got all of the information then
they can make their decision
um
says a way to look at submission is like
this I will always respect and submit to
the president even if I don't like him I
am submitting to the position that he
holds uh Danny said this is for get
Pearl the summer AC funds yeah yeah we
do need summer we need AC in here oh
[__] does that make sense to you that
what he said yeah that's very powerful
yeah
um no I I don't think you're like I
think a lot of times in the church they
don't really talk about submission it's
odd like not not in the true sense they
do in the sense of like submitting to a
higher being and it's been to like the
will of God and the will of the the
Bible itself but like interpersonal
submission not too much they mention it
it gets mentioned but it doesn't get
like delved into it like great detail
outside of like God man submit to him
and that one gets fleshed out more than
man to man if that makes sense
yeah I think I think there's a lot of
selective politicking with when it comes
to religion so 100 and I think
everyone's out here they're they're
beating they're enjoying life they're
drinking they're doing the thing and
then it's traditional in a sense when
you need to do this so listen
when it suits you when it suits you yeah
I'm just gonna hit the point and say
that they don't mention it because the
majority of uh church goers are now
women and they're catering to women so
if they're pre-submission you're not
going to get much of an audience really
damn there you go the church has been
very feminized wow
I mean why do you think they have like
gay flags in the church now no yeah
men are really pushing that that's right
but is that to do with remember it's got
to do with fitting in like the whole
lgbtq plus I can't remember the whole
name yeah
um it's like a it's like a common thing
now it's like it's a big thing now so
it's like it will like businesses will
now push it and say we support this
because it brings like publicity and
sells or whatever whatever you do or
whatever I know me and I know many
people that are gay or whatever many of
us don't give a damn
I didn't even know we had Flags you know
what probably two of my Magnum friends
at all and they asked me my opinion on
something I said bro I didn't even do
you telling me more about the community
than me I said I didn't even know I said
okay bring up lgbtq plus plus
uh blessing can you play one of the
videos I was gonna get the reaction to
it I'm gonna read the first I think I
missed one or two super chats I'm gonna
go and get them
um all right guys make sure you like the
video that's the most important metric
which video do you want Festival uh you
can just pick one and they're all
they're all
um
hold on guys um also guys if you have
any questions for the panel make sure
you send it via Super Chat uh okay I
read that one read that one
uh
uh read that one okay red
190.
hey um shout out to Dallas y'all a
little translation for you I just get
along better with guys equals three over
at four squared pretty sure it's the
same access across the pond as it is
here Barrett women to um like to test
men more men we like to keep it simple
as is there's no tests the truth comes
out in the wash
uh Xena W Pearl reaction channels are
fake news that is true
um okay Barrett
Church churches are starting to become
part of the world versus being in the
world and not of it they're failing
God's message and their followers uh
okay that's it
you want to play the video
what a woman hit the lottery for 1.3
million dollars right she hid it from
her husband and 11 days later divorced
her husband he found out two years later
from a letter in the mail it was the
lottery company saying do you want to
get the lump sum or do you want to
continue getting the monthly earnings
okay because that they didn't like
recognize that they were divorced
because he stayed at that same address
right so he got the letter but they were
divorced at this time two years later
correct but she won the lottery at the
time and they're married he sued her and
for fraud oppression and Malice ended up
winning 100 percent
plus she had to pay the court fees on
her end
what king win
100 100 oh yeah what'd you guys think of
that she was wrong yeah right he won he
won Batman won don't try it don't try it
she tried it
for a while though I'm guessing she
would have got some payments monthly
until the letter came through and he
realized or whatever crazy because you
know this made national news that a
woman was you know taking all of a guy's
earnings but women do that all the time
yeah
no because this this one's funny because
it's a different amount so yeah I know
that's a big amount of money you know
she was taking I need one legally they
want everything as well because only did
he win money not only did she have to
pay the legal fees he also found out the
kind of woman is what I thought yeah
that's probably because I'm guessing he
never had any kids with her if he had
kids with her he wouldn't have been a
different situation because of liability
and blah blah blah and remember what he
earns and yeah
I'm talking about 100 I'm saying the
reason why he would have 100 he couldn't
have had you know any liability with her
with with actual kids no that's because
she was lying you know it's interesting
they looked at what happened when like
each sex won the lottery and the
probability of divorce and how do you
think it turned out
yeah yeah it was like the majority of
the men's state from the majority of the
women but see that that goes to show who
who is responsible with the power of
Leverage
um
elaborate so the power of Leverage you
be in the breadwinner you having a
life-saving amount is that something
that you're going to want to push into
the tree that you already have or is
that something that you're gonna go and
want to do like more selfish things and
go and you know do something independent
you know what I mean because bearing in
mind in that marriage you'll have gone
through things where you're both broke
you're going through things you know I
mean not even like a yo I want a lottery
but here take that this is my money but
boom here take that or and another
nothing like that just just up and left
I can imagine if you know I'm married my
wife divorces me then I see her in
the
idea that men will leave you for a
younger woman before like no fault
divorce was introduced isn't even
correct even before no fault divorce
like women would still leave men more
like they always have right I see that
being true I didn't know that wow yeah
because a lot of people no because it's
a propaganda campaign because basically
um with the women's suffrage movement
they just put like all of this
propaganda in the media to like take men
out of the home basically and tell women
that like we need a career more than we
need that but then again you need to
look at this so men are proposing
sometimes it's not really
I don't know it's the guy that's made
that big decision sometimes the girl
might be like yeah your boyfriend
material but I didn't want to break up
with you but now we're married
and I didn't really think I'd spend the
rest of my life I've dated a lot you
know what I mean but now we're married
things have just moved faster than I
really cared for them to at the time I
thought I'd just go with the flow and
I'm comfortable and they might not
actually think boom like this is not
even the I might grow out of love with
this person but for the guy because he's
making all these
um intentional move movements with you
of course it's a no-brainer well I got
more money to do things boom yeah Let's
Stay Together I also think maybe like I
don't I'm just guessing here but going
with your scenario I feel like maybe
women sometimes like
they just want a wedding day like they
don't want a marriage they just want a
wedding day someone proposes oh I can do
this and take loads of Instagram
pictures with my girls and all and like
it's something about me like
so you know it makes sense I had this
conversation with a friend the other day
on gay weddings and I said um and I said
I understand why a woman want to get
married because the whole bridesmaids
and the whole world I said why why men
would want to marry another man that's
just a waste of money in time and the
guy said oh yeah blah blah blah man I
have everywhere I weren't trying to say
men don't have right to marry another
man I'm just trying to say I understand
why a woman wants it but I don't
understand why a man would wishes don't
know you know what the man it's
intentional like you said you know
because there's so much more especially
in this day and age now and the climate
that we're living in there's so much
more at rest for the guy like that that
is a clear signal from the man that he
is committing to you because you know
and then if you're a girl
and you then just sort of just say yes I
can see it happening would you guys get
married without a wedding
no no yeah what's the point you went out
no why just because I think it's such a
and I'm not one of those girls who's
like dreamed of this big white wedding
my whole life like I still don't really
know too much where I want my wedding
and stuff but I think it's just a nice
way to just bring everyone that you love
and share that special memory with them
to be honest team's cool that's what
Christmas
isn't it roast turkey family you only
see once a year what if he says that
okay we don't have like money right now
um let's just go to the courthouse and
get this thing done I want to be your
husband isn't that more important than
the wedding I mean that's what my
parents did to be fair
why can't you do it I mean yeah I would
it's not that I wouldn't want to do it
but I'd also want that big special day
would you
be comfortable with getting that done to
learn say that again would you be
comfortable with with getting that big
day down the line as more like a
certificate of your your union and
marriage yeah I could do that small now
and then big maybe five years ten years
yeah I could do that why is it not
enough to just have been picked though
like if a guy is literally telling you
he wants to marry you like why why do
you need some kind of signification that
you've achieved this great thing like
why is it not just enough in your heart
that this is
you wanted it earlier yeah I agree with
that why do you need a legal
documentation
don't get me wrong of course it's it's
nice like you say you get your family
and friends together yeah who doesn't
want that especially when you know
because the bride's family meets the
group family like that's that's lovely
but at the end of the day the marriage
signifies a partnership and a commitment
and
why why do you need that wedding day so
he asked if you would take it if you had
that big day down the line would you do
it if there was no big day he just
wanted to be your husband but you didn't
have the money for a wedding so like
that was it you just go to the
courthouse or whatever and get the
document would you do that I mean of
course if I was completely in love with
the man and I wanted my I saw a future
with him and I wanted to live my life
with him of course I'm not gonna say no
do you know what I mean because it is
about the marriage at the end of the day
but just for me I love memories and I
think that would be a celebration of
what's to come so for me it's like it's
at the beginning of the story what about
the memories that you'd make in the
marriage yeah of course but it would be
like it would be like a celebration of
the beginning of the future
couldn't you make memories in him asking
you the feeling that you get knowing
that he wants to make that commitment
walking down to the courthouse together
having that private moment together then
whatever you do a glass of champagne
yeah yeah you don't need everyone else
to confirm that you've done something
great you don't need to seek validation
from everyone else if you want a
courthouse
I've got a question for you uh for the
women yeah would you would you women
agree or disagree that the more a man
has to kind of do in the relationship is
like the less you kind of like him as a
person
so for instance if he has to do the most
big wedding big this big that he's
lacking he's kind of lacking because
without that you you said you have to be
in love with him 100 and all these other
factors whereas if you really just you
you mess with him as an individual he
doesn't really have to do the extras
because I notice if I'm not someone's
cup of tea I might have to jump through
a hoop or two if I'm a cup of tea but
we're we're chilling on biscuits it's
all good you know I mean so there's a
difference so would you guys agree or
disagree with that basically I think
what he's saying is you said that you
would do the courthouse yes if you love
them 100 let's say you love them 17 then
I wouldn't get married does he have to
do the white wedding
I think you're right the more you have
to do for a girl the less she probably
does like yeah yeah it [__] yeah
because when you're when you're really
into a guy you're always like thinking
about what he wants what he you're happy
just to be around him yeah yeah yeah
yeah listen to Amanda them listen to
that because if you're doing the most it
means you don't like she's not into you
like that or for real yeah you set a
president as well to say you know what
for you to be with me I have to come
with all these things men don't realize
how valuable valuable tension is like
because I think women would not we would
not survive without male attention if
men treated their attention like it was
a valuable women would have a very
different Behavior yeah
I've been watching capybara tick tocks
for a long time right
you know the animal the capybara I don't
know what that is seriously imagine if
every guy said you know what I'm not
gonna accept a girl that has slept with
double-digit people I'm not gonna accept
women
um that are overweight I'm not gonna
accept women with children out of
wedlock women would make different
decisions yeah like imaginative like
women would not leave their husbands if
they didn't think there was a simp
waiting for them they would not women
would not they would stay but it's like
because men will give like their
attention which is so it is so valuable
like we cannot survive without male
attention that's why women without dads
like they're messed up
because they didn't get that male
attention so they have to go somewhere
else male attention is valuable and if
men were more selective with who they
gave it to I think women like would be
better in a way yeah that's true but
doesn't that link to the whole thing
where um the other thing was like guys
only go as far in terms of court and as
women allow oh true so like so like back
in the day Victorian times why did
everyone back then used to call and used
to wear like the big corsets and have to
date each other someone for like two
months before you could eat it no it's
not it's not no it's not the men's
responsibility oh yes the women's the
sexual market like the the peer of women
is the women's responsibility because
we're in control of sex exactly but I do
think that the the quality I don't want
to say quality but
that have no business being wife that
should be in the streets forever or that
have had like if you have two different
baby daddies why is anybody marrying
yeah
Britney Renault yeah Brittany Reno
friend of the show
everybody she's one of those girls in
that type of type of situation but it's
like you know her past so well that like
there's no way do you think for some
women can just be really unlucky like
they fell for somebody she's not one of
those women fell for somebody
how the kids
in the same argument as you were saying
earlier about if you should have
children or not and you said oh it's a
woman's body I imagine you were
referring to abortion and and you have
the right I think you're in complete
control so you have complete control to
not open your legs to every man yeah but
people get divorced too
and that's not even like a small amount
a lot of people get divorced I'm not
even trying to be what's the percentage
but the women are the ones divorced yeah
like yeah I mean there's definitely a
part to play in that apart no but what I
was trying to say is if I have a
relationship with a with a female and
I'm with her for five years and I have a
child and then I have a relationship
with someone else for a year and I have
a child
I have a really good solution here okay
don't have sex with people you don't
want to have kids with for us or you
know use birth control of some sort yeah
you know there's there's like a billion
different forms you can pick one
um and maybe you know if you have a kid
with someone stay yeah
those are three valuable values you know
unhappy just because you have but what
about the kids happiness why does
everyone everyone always go to their own
happiness what about the kids happiness
children who come from single parent
homes unfortunately statistically are
worse off that is a fact so you are
going against the odds for the sake of
your your go you're forcing your child's
life against the odds for the sake of
your momentary happiness happiness is a
feeling they last temporary like all
feelings whereas that child's
development is permanent because of the
way that the brain develops everything
that happens in childhood is a building
if you have a kid that's in a single
mother home she's more likely to go to
jail she's more likely to drop out of
school they're more likely to be
sexually abused by the stepdad they're
more likely to have mental health issues
every she's read every statistical
disadvantage you could put your kid out
you're putting them at work because
you're not happy yes you're in control
of your happiness well that's that's
when we get into the maturing thing
happens is that happiness kind of has to
take a back seat yeah yeah because not
everything's gonna be happy all the time
I hear it but at the same time
I think male or female if you're in a
abusive relationship whether it's verbal
abuses
like they put this in the media like
we're so afraid of these men that are
just abusing women all the time it's
like five percent if that of men that
commit the majority of the crimes and
what percent of them are incarcerated
yet women pick man that's incarcerated
women pick these dangerous men and then
why yeah and then why would I have
friends so it's like am I am I gonna
feel bad for you that you picked it back
that's who you picked you made a kid
with him work it out decisions have
consequences
and you make no because a lot of times a
lot of people need to realize that the
decisions that you make don't only just
affect you it affects everyone around
you and I see it like today when we had
um we had four girls come on the show
for like the cat lady or um wife show
and I think did all four come from
single mother homes I think all four
either three out of four or four dead
and you can see it in the way they view
relationships like they all say
partnership like they don't even
understand that husband and wife is a
role it's like they don't know basic
things said and then it's like you get
these kids that have never seen a
functioning relationship then our
generation can't have relationships
there's so many problems that come with
that like homelessness drug addiction
there's so many issues that come as a
result of single mother homes
um and and a lot of times it leads to
the birth rate declining yeah because
now I think we're at like 1.4 kids per
woman they're predicting that 50 of
women are going to be single and
childless yeah like so now 50 more women
that hit 30 are not going to have kids
that have them in the next couple of
years yes it's like it's like that thing
where you know when people say like
someone who bullies is someone who's
just being bullied in another situation
by someone else right it's kind of you
can you can liken that to the situation
because it's like if if one person sees
a bad relationship and they don't know
how to do a bad relationship all they
would know is what they've seen and what
they know to be true from the immediate
surroundings now if the immediate
surroundings are negative and every
example of a relationship is all
negative the only idea of a relationship
that they have in their head is most
likely going to refer back to negative
yes they will have the positive ones
from movies and stuff but they only know
negative also it's also about like the
way that behavior if you're the way that
humans behave is based off of what they
know we can only behave off of what we
know like if you go back to when we were
is it like hunter-gatherer at times like
that we our our brain Maps stuff out so
if if you've only seen bad stuff like
you say you might see good stuff in the
in the movies but you're not the one
actually going through the experience
you're going to repeat that pattern of
unhealthy relationships because it's all
that your brain has actually experienced
like and it doesn't even have to be but
sometimes you can do the complete
opposite because you've been you were
raised in that household and you saw and
you're like this is how I don't want my
marriage sure
you can't you can but statistically they
don't yeah it's hot like like why do you
think we don't even have to look at
Stats to know this why do we say that
girls have Daddy Issues
there are ramifications for not having
functioning happy relationships and I
also think it turns men into Sims where
they don't know how to deal with women
um because like they've never seen a
masculine man lead in a relationship and
then you have all the women complaining
that there's no masculine man it's like
trying to explain the color red to
someone who's colorblind if you've never
seen the color red how do you explain it
like have you seen have you guys heard
of the the inmates and the uh the the
prisoners and the um the guards
psychological like experiment that
happened that they did well the um
Stamford prison the Stanford ones I met
the guy who did Zimmerman
right so this experiment essentially
like they they had a room full of people
they split them in half students half of
them were um um inmates and the other
half were guards and they realized after
a certain amount of time the guard
started acting like actual gods and the
prisoners like that to like actual
prisoners and they started to have like
an actual power
and he had to shut it down early because
the the the guards were like really
taking in as like this is their life and
these people are actually actually
villainous people the reason I bring
this up is to show like this is a real
life psychological example of what it
looks like to be surrounded by images of
things that you don't really understand
that is an example of like being
surrounded by a negative image of what
you think should happen only going off
your idea of what is what should happen
and seeing how the human mind goes with
that because they were quick to take on
the roles of prisoner and jailor three
days it was like three to five days or
something and they flipped they were
they were gonna kill these people like
people were like locked up when solitary
confinement so it goes to show the
reason I've been up is to show that like
the psychological the psychology of
human beings is so like fragile yeah I
was gonna say frigid or like fragile
that like things around you that you see
every day that you don't even realize
that you see or hear or you experience
shape you right so to continuously show
kids right because I'm out like I've
seen it myself there's so much single
parents stuff shown on there was a
period of time where single parent stuff
was shown a lot right and it just
becomes something that's like very
natural and very joke all right which
which shows up even in fairy tales like
Cinderella they never they never they
never
like they always remind someone and the
stepmom's always like disgusting but you
never really talk about the mom because
he was always past or something yeah and
it's always like one of those ones where
single parents like lifestyle had been
pushed not like directly but like
indirectly in different ways of like if
you if you notice it then you notice it
type of thing I just think that modern
women are selfish when it comes to their
kids they care about themselves more
than their kids yeah and I think it's
really sad and I think it actually ruins
Society because when you put yourself
before your kids you mean you put your
generation before the Next Generation
but are there enough okay let me um
backtrack a bit so to the point of like
um people that are not having kids
um drinking there's enough women that
have passed that point of being able to
get pregnant
they'll actually speaking to younger
women and saying all right let's know
because that involves swallowing their
pride and they don't want to do that but
guy there's enough guys saying hey get
your get your act together it goes you
know you need money you need to you need
to do this you need networks you need to
be able to
um defend yourself you know there's
enough I feel like there's there's
enough guys doing that I just want to
know from the women are there women are
doing that no no there's a fundamental
difference between guys and girls guys
will give guys genuine advice girls
won't if you heard the whole thing
because girls compete with each other
because if you're 25 and the girl that's
38 you're competing with her for the
same guy you've heard the phrase ago um
a guy will insult a guy and not mean it
a girl will compliment a girl and not
mean it right so it's one of those ones
where those older girls he would think
would give those advice might say to you
oh you're so pretty you should do this
but like they don't mean it but when you
see girls like uh commenting on obese
girls pictures like beautiful love it
like what are you doing it's not what
you're doing why are you encouraging her
yeah because look when I say I say like
this yeah with um with men I don't care
like you look at even Kevin yeah
I didn't care about the delivery because
he's not talking to me directly people
call up and you know they go oh yeah but
if you're not talking to that person
directly you can see the delivery and
look at that as entertainment but you
can still take the message I think with
women it needs to be dissected in a way
that makes them directly to them
specifically
feel they've got to feel great about it
to receive it whereas with guys I might
like generally speaking I'll just be
like cool yeah what he's saying is makes
sense makes sense and you move on yeah
and I'm and I apply it or I don't apply
it you know I mean but I believe there's
enough men out there given that
direction and I think you know just from
a conversations that we've had here just
through on the panel you know is it
working for you to if you want if you
know what you you want kids and you want
this kind of you want a certain kind of
lifestyle you want things
is the way you're moving working for you
and if there if it isn't do you have
people in your life that are saying that
you can talk to that haven't had kids
and they can say boom all right look you
know time's ticking it will get to this
point and this is how I feel now that I
waited and I'm here yeah but you know
you know what it is with the the biggest
enemy to women most times is other women
so like because we can't even admit
there's a problem yeah other women are
the downfall of women yeah for a lot of
time because they will be the ones who
feed you the stuff that you want to hear
in one side knowing good and down well
that's not the advice you need to hear
and then Lee and then what you work out
that door and made that mistake
I'm gonna read you guys I'm gonna read
you guys some stats um some of these are
from the us some of these are from the
UK so you know
take them with a grain of salt but one
in four women have an STD one in three
women have had an abortion geez 38 of
kids are born into single parent homes
the average age of first child is 26 and
the average age of first marriage is 30.
45 of marriages end in divorce the
average number of sexual partners for a
woman is between four and eight and
after um women have slept with more than
five people she has a 20 chance of
having a happy marriage after 10 years
if men get divorced
um they can be financially ruined and
their kids can be taken from them
seventy percent of women are overweight
ninety percent of women have used
contraceptives at some point in their
reproductive years and most have used
more than one method throughout their
lifetime so it's like how do we look at
these numbers and say we're doing well
as a whole
you know and I'm not saying you know
that
like because they'll always say what
about them I'm not saying men don't have
issues too but it's like we can't even
talk about our problems without people
always having to point out the men like
we can never even just have a
conversation about the issues that we
have as women without simps or women
coming in saying but men have problems
too like we can't even have one
conversation about it whereas back in
the day women used to actually sit down
together discuss things and or they'd
say you're not dressed well you're not
yeah we used to actually like catch each
other up on stuff like you know oh
you're showing too much like you're
presenting yourself this way or you know
even something silly like you didn't
brush your hair like I feel like
nowadays like girls sort of tiptoe
around each other and they don't even
want to like tell their friend like it
depends what type of girl you are though
if I'm completely honest I think if
you're insecure and you're unhappy with
what you're doing yourself then you're
gonna be [__] to other people but if
you're happy and content you've got to
support and you know what I mean so I
think it's the individuals I don't think
I don't think supporting I think real
supporting is being honest yeah but
that's what I mean like she said you
might not tell your friend if they
haven't brushed you yeah no I said as
well but some girls wouldn't but that's
because they're like oh well yeah they
kind of want us to know what I mean
because they're unhappy with themselves
which goes back to what I said a lot of
times the women's worst enemy is another
woman yeah because a guy would point out
the fact that uh your shirt's kind of
inside out yeah
I believe like chastising someone in
public is different like I don't think
you should do that in front of other
people yeah of course not you should
take if that's your real friend they
should be able to take him to the side
and say hey man
and we can respect that and we won't
look at that as like you being [__] on
it it's like you know when you eat
something you've got something in your
teeth up please tell me
like even if you go yeah it's like just
told me you know I mean so I think you
know because even at the beginning of my
relationship with my with my girl now I
had to tell her I we had a conversation
I was like if there's an issue that you
see please just tell me right there and
then I don't want this whole passive
aggressive thinking about it for two
weeks don't bring it up and then Vixen
talking to your girlfriend to buy a
behind my back and this whole [__]
month period I had no idea this so this
this is an issue that you had all right
with that are you able to accept the
delivery I don't care about the level of
her problem in in any form yeah I don't
care about delivery it's just about it's
just about what gets said because if if
with me it's like if I disagree with
what you was saying then we have a
discussion about what I disagree but
like delivery is one of those things I
get an example right let's say for
instance it's in the bedroom something
that's sensitive right something like
boom ah you're not doing this right
if she thinks about it and then she's
kind of let's say you're having a
stressful week at work or whatever yeah
and then she kind of puts that into her
into her mind and thinks about cool
maybe I approach it in this way as
opposed to just be like oh you can't do
this like you know if she if she
expresses the frustrations then and
there without thinking about it at all
or like seeking some kind of advice then
do you not think that can have some kind
of detriment to how you're able to get
over that or are you saying that
regardless of how she comes at you with
whatever she comes at you you're gonna
be able to swallow it and move on as
normal kind of I get where you're coming
from but it but then I have to equate
that to like all right let's let's talk
about like equate that to like football
if your if your manager says you need to
be there you're going to be upset with
him because uh my mind oh I'm having a
really bad week at home so my manager
has to talk to me a certain type of way
if the information with me per se and I
know I'm I'm I'm a very black sheep when
it comes to this my girlfriend always
says to me you have the emotional
capacity of a wooden spoon because I
don't really care about like emotions
too tough if the information is
necessary please tell me and I'll do the
same all right but he's talking sexually
you mean yeah he's fully pleasing a
woman right and then the worst thing of
a woman a woman would tell you a lot of
women talk with each other about exactly
sex
they're part of their Partners this and
what that partner is doing and what
you're not doing and then that girl with
your partner would bring that in the
bedroom and go oh well my friend tried
this and blah blah blah and if you ain't
satisfying her in a certain way if you
come at me at like a aggressive kind of
way like it will hurt my feelings
because remember when I'm having when
you're having sex with someone you're
completely vulnerable with each other
okay so which hurts more so when you're
talking about like so when you're
talking about like we when you met your
partner and you always said ah like no
matter what just tell me whatever like
you can tell me but you need to if it's
sexually like you need to tell me in a
certain way because I feel like I'm
doing the best I can do
I'm not doing the best I can do let me I
need you to maybe let me ask let me ask
a question which would hurt more her
directly saying you need to do this
better because you're not really doing
that that much or her going through all
of her friends and eventually saying to
you is she gonna go for a friend
eventually her saying it to you nicely
but now you know all of our friends know
the thing where people where girls talk
bro exactly so it's like if you didn't
fulfill a fantasy the first time she
already told her friends she probably
told her friend first and then she's
already come to you her friends already
know that's what I'm saying I want to be
the first to know yeah but it's too late
because girls talk she already told him
that's why you bring up a relationship
with his tail straight you don't know
that you're not in control of that a
woman's in control of that of course
women talk you're not in no obviously
you're not in no control of what a woman
thinks in the ways he took women talk
yeah no matter what you do you could be
the best guy the best at whatever you're
doing there because he's been in them
rooms
I know I'm talking about experience
because listen me I would only do
certain things on birthdays Valentine's
days and Christmas anyone that's been
with me knows what I'm talking about
yeah now if you're if your friend or
whatever gets it whenever once a week
like it's a it's a downfall and and I'll
be like yeah but you know like I do the
best I can do on a certain on a
celebration like it's something you look
forward to and we bring out the roses
and the petals and the whipped cream and
the chocolate sauce blah blah blah
you know what I mean I'm gonna take a
second to read uh super chats for a
second
um guys make sure you like the video
we're almost to 500 likes on this chat
so make sure you hit the like button
um okay
um also guys
um
make sure you send them to our Google
form that should be in the chat for the
events um that we're gonna do in the U.S
um Aeron Pearl and Blondie are spitting
so much fire right now it's crazy that
you're both laying out common sense but
that's so controversial these days uh
clown world baby
um I see young boys walking home from
high school with these girls just
yelling Waltzing talking acting 304s
it's damaging um to a boy's psyche Glenn
Bible tells the husbands to love their
wives like Christ loves the church it
also tells wives to submit in respect to
their husbands nowadays wives love
husbands and husbands submit and respect
to what submit and respect wives winter
and wait am I missing something did the
woman do wrong she won the lottery and
then she got sued a baby there is no
partnership in a relationship a team can
only have one leader divided leadership
always fails
um also men are more in touch with
reality um hi Donovan
um women only refer to God when they're
um talking about what they won't do for
a man goes to subscribe to Donovan's
Channel I'm he does reactions to my
stuff all the time Barrett churches are
starting to become a part of the world I
read that one already I'm gonna refresh
it real quick
um okay
do you want to do um the next video
blessing
would you tell me please who is the boss
of your house I'm the boss what do you
think you're his wife are you
what do you say I said who is the boss
my husband what is your nationality big
I'm Greek it's always that way in Greek
households the husband is a bus yes
don't the women the wives have anything
to say about it no
hmm
um so this is an older video how do you
think social media has changed that
dynamic
[Laughter]
uh podcasts
if you ask uh a girl and a guy the same
question that they asked there the
answer will be 100 different because if
you ask who's the leader of the
household the amount of times you were
here I have uh the woman say me or say
he thinks he is but it's not actually
it was something along those lines yeah
guys will get on TV and be like Oh happy
wife happy life that's the one that's
what they say that's the one some
anything along those lines and it's like
but like you should have some sort of
leader or whatever back then that's how
it was that's right this is what the man
just a simpler time easier you say back
then no no this this way that we're
living now is the new Norm for like the
entirety of mankind you understand that
right it's not back then it was for the
entirety of man's existence up until
about 30 years ago because this is what
this is how we were living but I don't
think there's like you know let's say
for instance there's a decision to make
in the household
you know you got the final says the man
are you
I think you get the Lions get quite
crossed in terms of like having any kind
of conversation with the pros and cons
of a situation with your woman I don't
feel like women just get like your
opinion and your mindset and everything
you bring to it it just should just be
wiped out I think a conversation can
happen yeah I do believe that you know
you've got to trust someone to lead you
know I mean if you need if he needs a if
he's gonna ask a question or run
something you know yeah and you're going
back and forth then cool but you know I
think sometimes women will hear this men
needs to lead and just think okay all my
education is and they put so much into
their education that they can't even
fathom the thought of Rod this isn't
even valuable in this relationship yeah
but marriages would last longer back
then but my grandparents my my Grandma
had no say less options though you know
what I mean less options maybe no I mean
marriages last longer so it was it
worked in their time now maybe that's
what it is though what you said about
education you you said uh
you've said it before about women who
have been to University more likely to
leave maybe it's not that's 90 you're 90
likely to leave in a divorce maybe it's
not a direct correlation between
education but rather something to do
with like Pride because if you've done
that education that's a commitment and a
sacrifice to do something for yourself
and then when you get into a
relationship maybe it's like oh you
don't want to let a man be the leader
because you feel like you've done
something worked hard at something I
just think it's to do with the fact that
you've got an educate because I've been
to UNI and stuff like that and I don't
feel I haven't got Pride because of that
I think it's more to do with if you've
got knowledge and wisdom to talk about
then you should be able to talk about it
but he would know that shortly and he
would so like for example I have a law
degree so if my partner ever had any
kind of legal question uh he was dealing
with something with his insurance like
he will ask me questions so I feel like
it's more of a case where if they need
you they will ask but what I'm saying is
I feel like a lot of women perhaps want
to know more because they have this
knowledge wisdom whatever so they want
to be able to exercise that and what I'm
saying is I don't really think that's
necessary and perhaps going to UNI and
getting it
I mean I hate to say it but it is a fact
that marriages lasted longer when women
weren't doing that so I'm just
questioning why that is because it is
factual that I hate it it's actually
inverse like college and kids so it's
like the more education a woman has the
less kids she has
um yeah
because it seems like when when women
get money they don't want men like they
don't want a man unless he's like the
man she wants yeah the thing about it
when guys become millionaires they go
for most if not any girl when a girl
becomes a millionaire she's looking for
someone who's making more Millions than
she is
or if she's smart in certain aspect then
she's looking for someone who is better
than her in whatever aspect is that's
true Eve Eve Eevee done the same thing
she went with a billionaire JLo I think
done the same thing people won't have a
billionaire
millionaires but there are rules with
his is it jar rule one of them is with
the same girlfriend that they were with
with everybody
they were the same original girl but all
these other movies
got the money and upgraded quote unquote
because you can't settle quote-unquote
because settling has to do with your
bank accounts and not your mentals
aspects nowadays
think I feel like something like your
education if you continue it doesn't
matter it doesn't matter do I get along
with you in the same way as your salary
doesn't really matter either
important and valuable are kind of look
in that um in relationships to help out
you know um if you've been with a woman
who's like
a nurse nutritionist like you know that
kind of nuts and stuff that guys do not
put any energy into whatsoever right
those kind of things are really a way
where guys will want to lean on their
girl and and of course in in those
circumstances you I mean when the car
breaks down other than
uh with someone oh no I was watching
something else where someone said they
can fix BMWs I think that was another
proof but like other than that it was
like uh you know there's certain things
that the guy might not necessarily need
your input at that time and you might
have so much to give him and you and you
might be thinking right why don't you
value my opinion or why aren't you would
you go on a podcast and act like you
don't care about my opinion but you know
you need to kind of focus on things that
are going to get you what you want and I
think sometimes our parents push
realities onto us but maybe just leave
that at work and then you've got to
learn when you come home put on a
different hat unwind yeah yeah I mean
um I think we're gonna close out the
show guys cool
um so we're gonna do final thoughts so
any
um like final thoughts Instagram you
want a shout out you can do that now
starting here and then go around
hello it's Ashton again so the Instagram
is it's Ashton Maria
um and just final thoughts um you know
how you were talking about guys in the
car breaking down and a woman really
wouldn't know what to do I was in a
situation quite recently where there was
my friend was driving us and there was
three four yeah four of us in the car
girls and it was the girls that sorted
the car situation because my friend was
like oh you need to jump start the car
my other friend was like oh let me call
like the AAA or just an insurance
company whereas he was very calm that
handled the situation fine but it wasn't
for him who
did the girls know what to do yeah more
than him interesting okay cool that's
yeah what's what's your like what's your
take on it I just think girls can do
anything really to be honest women are
super super women are superpowers
to me a woman can achieve
not to put men down but like a woman to
me I don't think a woman needs a man to
me I think a woman is so empowering and
can do anything they put their mind to
and they can work six days a week seven
days a week raise a family run a
mortgage like they can be everything and
I think women are just a different kind
of human being compared to a man and
that's where I stand in it probably
because I have so much respect for my
mother
um and seeing what I've seen from my
mother who had me at 20 and my dad being
27 and just seeing my mum run the whole
thing like you are you are crazy like I
can't mess with you a lot I think we're
brilliant honestly I agree
[Music]
I listen to it because I just like okay
cool um so the women I'm not saying that
women can't
um you know fix a car or you know change
of time and stuff like that I guess you
you said that he was quite calm and he
handled the situation I guess he was
still looking for him to delegate or say
I guess you're still looking for him to
have some kind of input in that right oh
no I mean you just like step aside the
girls have got this I don't know what it
was for me what I found attractive with
it was how he handled the situation he
didn't Panic he didn't stress he didn't
kick off he didn't have a tantrum he
just got on with it and that's what I
thought was attractive because that was
a man kind of just having control of the
situation yeah yeah that's what I found
it that's it that's an amazing input
because it didn't mean that women
weren't capable of changing yeah and it
didn't mean that okay I think most women
are capable of doing that yeah yeah you
know no I hear it but not every man is
capable of changing I think
significantly more than women yeah I
think stereotypically yeah yeah it might
not always be true though yeah but we
got to talk in like most of the time a
number so if I say like most men are
more masculine than women there's
exceptions but I think this day and age
though you I mean guys are very catering
now like they'll go to the salon and you
know they'll get their eyebrows done and
their nose done and everything whereas
back in the day
were you on the verge of seeing today
nowadays guys are more girls are more
masculine and guys is that where this is
going no but I think yeah
there's a lot of girls that are more
masculine energy and there's a lot of
guys that are more feminine I think I
agree with you though because I know
there's a lot of guys out there getting
pedicures kind of thing I don't agree
with all that I don't know
I see it on social media I think men are
supposed to be men I don't think there's
anything wrong with gay
but I think it lets down your
masculinity a bit okay
toes but then but then men so where do
you stop it men take when I was all
putting on makeup interest is that okay
if they want to yeah
we should have stopped it before having
a if they want to should not be enough
Tampax but yeah I was gonna bring that
up I don't think yeah
um
let's not get into it
[Music]
okay so yeah um you guys can follow me
uh my Instagram tashana talks uh my
YouTube channel is the same tashana
talks I talk about faith and my journey
with God mainly
um and final thoughts I think I got
checked about the whole submit the
submitting thing I think that uh the
comments some of the comments checks me
but it was a very thought-provoking
conversation and it's definitely made me
think you know more about how I'm going
to move in marriage it was just a
learning a learning experience so yeah
amazing thank you yeah thanks for coming
that's a good reaction some girls get
mad but see like I actually like it when
people can sit and think and like you
know yeah I'll definitely like sometimes
but know that comment about is just his
his position as being the man of the
house but my thing is in terms of the
man that I choose it's everything in
terms of like what I'm thinking is going
to start before we walk down the aisle
I'm going to look at your character I'm
going to look at your values I'm going
to look at everything before I even get
to that point of being at the aisle so
yeah I'm gonna be with someone that is
wise and that yeah that's what it should
be like but it's so weird how like even
that mind frame even seems weird in
today's day and age but you have to look
at someone's personality before you
sleep with them or before you get into
situations that you can't undo like how
many people do you have you heard of
that like before pregnant with someone
that they've had what four conversations
with or stuff like that and like it's
not pushed I think it's planned yeah
that's what I'm saying that like like
you're my mindset is so refreshing
especially today especially today in
today's day and age because a lot of
people don't have that mindset of
wanting to get to know someone before
before you move on to the next step a
lot of people are thinking flesh first
and then mine later mine and mind body
and soul later flesh first I think it's
always head first and then then flesh
what but can I just say like can I just
say that like some of what we spoke
about it was like a very black and white
situation like it was just very like
this is the situation what do you think
but I think that there's a lot of
different factors that like we didn't
discuss and so like for me in marriage I
want to be with somebody that's Godly I
want to be with somebody that loves
Christ I want to be with somebody that I
respect and all of those things and of
course it's going to be easy to submit
to somebody like that somebody that puts
God first in somebody that you know I
think it will be easy I think marriage
is hard I think marriage is hard I think
if you talk to any woman that's been
married for 20 30 40 years they're gonna
tell you it was not easy to submit all
the time yeah no and I I do I yeah I do
agree with that I do agree that marriage
is difficult but people like Instagram
or anything you want to shout out
thanks for having me back I like coming
on here because you know it's always a
good conversation
um shout loves you yeah thank you
um my Instagram is Christine Grace Smith
all traditional spelling
that's it cool um yeah I had something I
wanted to bring to the church
um just quickly ending I wanna I really
like diverging into the day and
experience so I kind of wanted to know
like especially from the women like how
do you feel
um dates go and do you feel like they go
in the right direction I'm talking like
First Dates do you reckon they're kind
of on average this is something that you
get nervous about is it something that
um you think guys kind of have down
packed like what is that experience like
for you guys that first date
not going into it
anyone
um oh I'll speak I think for me I always
get really really nervous before first
date
um I want to be with somebody that's
like a leader that like has things
planned and like if he's coming with
this energy of just like oh like would
you want to do like me taking me to the
movies like that's not a day in my eyes
because I don't feel like you're really
getting to know the person I think it
should be an opportunity for you guys to
talk and get to know each other and so
um yeah and I you know I recently had
this issue about like paying on the
first date but that would just open up a
whole conversation I think the guy
should pay I think the guy should pay
even in pursue that in that said let's
go on a date
um I wouldn't I don't think I would ask
the guys to go on a date with me but I
think if a man is is is pursuing me and
asking me out in a day I think that he
should cover that I think I believe in
being a gentleman I think for girls
[Music]
um
just going off of what we were saying
about uh like
contraception and everything like if
you're not on birth control I would say
always aim for a date where alcohol
isn't involved because I was talking
about you said something that triggered
my mind where you said about a girl
having lots of sexual partners or she
might have just had a bad experience
falling for a bad guy whatever
um
if that's how we women are which is fair
enough to say because we're emotional
beings
um be careful so don't drink when you go
on a first date and then you probably
hopefully might not make a silly Choice
um interesting and yourself
me yeah
um do you know what I actually don't go
on that many dates to be honest I'd kind
of like to know the person before it got
to that because I'm not not I'm not a
not good person I can chat for days and
I can get on with anyone
um but for me it takes I'm a very
confident person so I would want my man
to be very confident and because I kind
of naturally do lead I'm a natural
leader so it'd be nice for someone to
put me in my place do you know what I
mean just kind of take the ruins and
kind of just have things sorted up yeah
yeah I'd probably like him to have
things planned and he'd put this and do
do you know what I mean interesting what
about you how do like how like how do
you feel about first dates do you feel
like guys have that kind of down pack do
you feel nervous going on a first date
like what is your biggest anxiety like
conversation this now what what is your
um your process
usually if I go on a date I already know
him from somewhere
um
I guess
my biggest anxiety I don't really get
anxious before dates okay
so it's kind of just like someone that
you usually kind of know and it's just
like you're just meeting up it's kind of
casual okay cool
cool yeah no I asked I know I couldn't
even extend it to the guys as well but I
asked because
um you know sometimes people have like
really bad experiences or really good
ones I like to
um I feel like there's a way in which
you can kind of break the ass make the
person feel confident and um that'll be
something that I'm gonna start venturing
into
um this year so focus on that and uh
follow me at 90 ranks and I'll kind of
be spending more time on that
wow yeah
[Laughter]
uh now I like that man I like that my
thing's different with dates anyway
because I just kind of say let's just go
Vibe and see how it goes that's my thing
because I feel like dates and putting a
label on certain things just adds to
pressure and people react most people
drink on dates because it loosens them
up or whatever I just kind of want you
to be your natural self vice versa so I
feel like if I say look let's just go
Vibe where do you want to go Vibe let's
go to this cocktail bar in elephant
castle cool let's go what time you want
to go there I'll be there for about five
cool I roll up about 4 45 I'll be
outside waiting there's no pressure on
each on either side yeah that's kind of
where I'm at in my early 30s that's
where I'm at anyway but yeah
um Wayne Elaine uh V1 Vibes my Instagram
is EO positive vibe that's energy of
Positive Vibes Zed at the end
cool cool
uh yeah uh every time I've come every
time I've come on these podcasts I've
always had quite a lot of fun my uh
leaving point my lasting point is
definitely needs to like I understand
the nuances and what they do and and why
they do what they do
understand the psychology of why you
make the actions that you make because a
lot of the things that you do in life is
a third party putting that in your mind
in some way shape or form right so we
always have to really really really be
careful when we look at like the actions
we take and why we take them because I
understand the psychology of why we take
those steps let lets us better
understand what kind of person we are
what kind of person we want to be the
things that we find attractive and why
and and it can help you better
understand yourself
so that's just like a tangent that means
nothing right but like but like it's
just a anyone who's watching just please
understand the psychology of your own
mind Understanding Psychology of the
people who are around so then you can
understand
how to take steps in this world right
and uh social media I don't really use
social media but you can follow me on
the underscore Franklin one if enough
people message saying that they want a
YouTube channel I will make one
I guess
thank you guys all for coming
um couple announcements guys before we
end the show again I will not have shows
um for I don't know until like second
week of June or something so I'm gone
for a minute but we're gonna do meetups
in
um I think Santa Barbara maybe La uh um
Miami Vegas uh Nashville and maybe DC
those are the I think those are the six
cities we're going to so
um sign up to our Google Forum that
should be in the chat and maybe pinned
in the comments
follow my Instagram if you have topics
you want to see me cover just probably
things one like the video on your way
out and I'll talk to you next time
what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
the pregame
yo what's going on people King
again with another podcast good evening
and hi and welcome to Auntie Jenny's
video Jenny's podcast it's your boy The
Fresh Prince
but I've been coffee free for four
months okay I gotta say that how could
everyone have someone out there for them
when there's more women than men like
I'm not saying you have to be submissive
to every old waste man walking around
I'm just saying that it would be
femininity would be in your nature
breaking it is to find somebody you're
compatible with that you'd like not just
of your same generation and that likes
the same things that you do going out
having fun get out okay okay then then
get out then get out faster then get out
I'm not here to get canceled today most
men want a woman that has some degree of
femininity where they feel like they're
taken care of taking care of and lady
like I'm submissive and you'll be
surprised because I will say what I want
to say now and I'll say what I want to
say with my mind but my demeanor doesn't
change and I'm gonna look down on him
because at the end of the day whoever
you're with is a reflection of you what
has happened to society that has made
the normal man a waste man I would feel
it feels so bad asking a guy to buy like
a three thousand dollar bag
now he's
foreign